Hey, what's up guys? This is a video just for you fans that've been watching for a long time and sending me emails about wanting to buy some of the things from my previous videos.
Now I've never ever had the time or resources in the past to make products because I'm focusing on making videos for you
But I do have a team of guys now who actually have connections to manufacturing and turning some of these things into products.
So what we need to know from you is what do you want me to make!
If we were to turn some of my projects into products which ones would you want to see? Which ones would you want to buy?
Kind of what we're thinking is imagine if a little pocket slingshot came in a kit.
You know it had three or four different pieces that you just assemble  father son gets together
spends an evening together and make a little backyard pocket slingshot.
You can put ammunition in there, screw the cap on tight and carry it around in your pocket
That's very very cool or what about a laser assisted blowgun?
It comes in maybe three or four pieces; snap it all together; pop a laser on top and now you're in business
Shooting marshmallows around the backyard. That would be cool!
But something like the bottle blaster you get the base
And you just use water bottles to screw on and make sonic exploding targets
[It would be] very cool if you put a little chalk dust in there to make a very colorful explosion as well
And we could do them a bunch of different ways we could make kits
We could send monthly packages of things for you to put together or we could send the products themselves
Built and intact and of course the Lego silicone mold, you can use chocolate you can use.
Actually you could even cast your own crayons, melt down crayons and make little Lego crayons, that'd be pretty sweet and
You know so rather than getting a two-part mix and having to mix it yourself,
It would just come pre-made or maybe you do want to mix it yourself. Maybe we put together some kind of kit for you, and
Make kits available. So right now this is kind of a choose-your-own-adventure
I need to know from you what you want, and they do not have to be these products guys
I just chose these because these are some of the suggestions you've reached out to me for.
Do we take King of Random to the next level and start making products? The choice is yours!
I just wanted to chat with you for a second and see if this is something you really wanted.
If there's enough interest maybe we will start making products and wouldn't it be cool if we started putting together a King of Random camps.
Where we can get together and make projects together in the camping setting?
I don't know got kind of a lot of ideas right now, but only if you're interested
This is really for you guys!
So check the link for the description to the survey give us as much honest feedback as you can because
we're going to be building programs based on what you want.
Really trying to reach out and meet the needs that you have. You can also click right here to take the survey
I'll put a little box that should take you straight to it
If you're on a mobile phone just look for the card to pop up click that and it'll take you over the survey as well
So tell me what you want. Let's see where the king of random goes from here